[Applause]
who's not going to take the tonight i
wouldn't do the tonight show now
uh well now i mean this is when
tonight's show is
the biggest thing on earth when he takes
it right uh
so but like who if someone offered you a
talk show
on something i don't know like i don't
know i mean it's just so different now
yeah it's different but yeah i mean
there's just certain you said you
wouldn't do netflix either and you did
that
i'm alive maybe you wouldn't i'm yeah
right now
you're gonna end up hosting this night
show would you do because you're now you
get that is that how you get stuff
you're like i would never do
nate shut the [ __ ] up this is how it
works bro yeah i know y'all edited that
out
i'm not even in the picture no
i um yeah i don't know i guess i don't
know i mean it's okay to want somebody
to continue i think i would
the comic that you like them yeah as
like for example a lot of people like
you because you're clean and then all of
a sudden you flip and you go
dirty there might be people go you know
might as if i could see dirty
and then you might defend it by being
like look i got a show on [ __ ] hbo
they wanted me to be dirty and then now
i got to be dirty now and they'll be
like all right well i'm
allowed to not like you because you
changed who you are yeah
i liked you for this reason you're no
longer that so that's why i don't like
you
i think that was the relationship with
leno to a lot of people i never knew him
as a stand-up before that yeah
right but i i heard he was [ __ ]
killing like murder that's the stories
always
yeah and like i weirdly love him for the
car show i watch hours of his
car show on youtube he became a youtuber
yeah it's the most amazing transition
he went from he went from the tonight
show host yeah
to a [ __ ] youtube never spent his
tonight show money was what they always
say
yeah live off the stand up money and
then just put that somewhere pretty wild
wild
i i don't know i i always i was like but
i do i'm okay with people like uh
changing their tune on someone if that
person changes who they are
yeah you know i'm fine with that too
like if they if they want to if they
that's why you want to stick to what you
do like there's not there's too many
times where you know i remember like
howard stern would always talk about
that with napoleon dynamite with him
that actor
yeah but being like yeah go do that
again man he's like nah i'm not doing
that now you're like well that's
why we like you and then because that's
the thing like that's what he was
yeah like that was uh that was such a
random
occurrence that that guy ended up
playing himself
like so i don't think he wrote the
[ __ ] movie right he was just the
actor yeah but somebody wrote a movie
and then there just existed that human
being and then he like
that's nuts yeah like yeah it's not
often you just write a random kind of
borderline spectrum
well it's definitely spectrumed out
character and then they exist
and then they [ __ ] murder it yeah but
if that's who you are you can't really
change that
like he's not going to go be in a
[ __ ] drama mclovin
didn't be he wasn't mclovin again and
now yeah why where's mclovin
yeah his name is mclovin he's mclovin
isn't that weird though that like that
happens like
you have these characters they get
typecast and then like they do like a
few movies and then they fall off and
people like yeah he's done it's like
no no they were like the star of movies
like that's really
awesome movies yeah like how many people
are in
film like the stiffler character was so
[ __ ] funny do you know like he was
just so he like curated this character
out of nowhere he just made this up he
invented that's not who he is
he just invents his character it's
incredible it makes us laugh and all
these other movies
and then it stops making us laugh and
then his career is over but like
he's not some loser like the guy was a
[ __ ] superstar yeah a little bit well
that's how he saw
we talked about sandler you're like
sandler just does him i love it like and
then he goes and
he did uncut gems and he's done a couple
like other kind of crazy things once in
a while i'll let you know he could act
he'll do one of those
he's great just like a little that's
like just wearing like a real nice watch
but you're like i'm doing all right dude
yeah like you know you got like a
t-shirt on and they're like is
everything okay you're like look
yeah i'm not worried about we're flying
don't worry about what's going on over
here all right i'll pay for this uh
like yeah he does like that kind of
thing but he builds his own yeah
that's what's great it's like you build
it is with what you're doing here in the
new kind of
way is like it's it is like you're
building your own world you can't have
to wrap your head around where you can
start going like all right
if i start you know you think about that
sometimes are you like
with you know yeah with specials and all
this you're like well if they're
here to see my special like how do i get
you got to get everybody
to switch yeah or if you're like well
what if i did do this but you like you
do it you're like
i'll put it out myself yeah because it's
like it's my thing
yeah and then you know not saying i'm
doing that but it's like
uh i was a very always a mainstream guy
yeah so i was very
you know i was never i never did good
like i'm still not going to this rock
venue like i needed my audience like it
was like it needs to be
the main comedy club in town yeah like
they were never going to find
the other club i mean they will they'll
go wherever you go but like
i subscribe to that too i don't want to
do comedy in a comic book store
i want to do comedy in the place that
it's supposed to be done yeah you're
coming into my home that's how i feel at
a comedy club i feel like it's my home
yeah and you're a guest
yeah if i go do like the weird off-site
thing
i feel like i'm i guess yeah yeah and i
like
it being my home yeah do you like
theaters
yeah i love the
sound i love the behavior i love like
that and like when you first walk on and
there's 2 000 people
you're just like what is this
like what is what is happening it's show
business it feels it feels the most like
show business there's union guys there's
yeah people are signing it we i've
talked
like you always feel uh we've talked
about like
uh an imposter feeling like you ever
when you go on you feel you're like who
are these people here to see
no you know they're there to see you no
i don't have yeah
that is something i haven't struggled
with and entertainment but i hear a lot
of
people talk about that yeah but i don't
i've only struggled that with
fame not with going on
age yeah yeah so like
initially getting some fame early when i
did the mtv stuff
i felt like i had to be funny like i was
on the show to a stranger
to justify where i was yeah i wasn't
comfortable enough with it
but the idea of like going up and
entertaining a group of people
in the way that like i i'm not lying
about who i am like who i am is who i am
so it's not going to be a surprise yeah
you know what i'm saying like that's new
york
this is it's like good for him but no
but like i'm not live
in that [ __ ] new
but i think it's like uh it's funny it's
like it's the
it's the personality of i wonder if it's
like being a new yorker like that's you
are very confident
uh i i think like when you vote like
you're very
it's yeah you're just you're the biggest
pond i think yeah well there's a
confidence to it that's like
you're you're friend you're from there
dude like you're not like it's not like
someone's like i live there you're like
yo dude i'm from
yeah you grew up there when it was
terrible and like uh
and it was like so you're there's like a
i don't know there's a different i think
i do think about this with home turf
and i i said this to you a couple times
like when i i've been in new york for
like 13 years now so yeah a little
different but before when i would go
back to dallas
i feel so confident dude i grew up here
i know this yeah
any show here is like bro i know this
[ __ ] i'm so confident
and this is not to take away from your
work ethic or talent or humor in any way
but being able to grow up in new york is
another advantage in addition to
everything else you do you're like yo i
know this place this is my place i think
it is a huge advance
i think i think that i've always looked
at you know comedy as like this um
combination of like extreme confidence
and extreme insecurity
and like the insecurity drives your
ability to get better and the confidence
has to be enough where you feel like the
things you say
should be said out loud yeah because
there'll be times i remember like
like it's always at the strip for some
reason like i'll be at the comic strip
and then i'll be like waiting to go on
and i'll be like
what is this oh yeah like why am i
like at the script what is this like why
am i i love this show i actually love
performing this trip but like
for whatever reason every once in a
while i have this and i'll be like why
am i
why are we talking to people like what
is this art yeah
like that i just go on stage and i say
things why is this funny why is this why
are they laughing
no no not necessarily why are they
laughing like why is this a fly does
this exist
why does this thing people pay money to
go like watch someone make them laugh
it's it's like it's the uh it's the i
guess
art version of you know when you say a
word enough and it just doesn't make any
sense oh yeah
it's that for the art like what is this
thing that we are doing
right now and why does this exist and
then you'll go on stage and just get
into it and all of a sudden it makes
sense but i'll have those like
little little feelings but i think that
that insecurity
like i have to be my harshest [ __ ]
critic i have to be like ah that [ __ ]
sucked
you can be better at that you can get
more efficient with your words and all
that kind of stuff but i have to be
confident where i should say it
because i think a lot of people i was
talking about buddy mine this weekend
like
he never even imagines himself having
uh people who support him so he's not
even trying to solve the problem of
how to get his stuff out to them he's
trying to solve the problem of
is my stuff even worth it for them to
listen to so he wouldn't even put it out
exactly like you knew you were gonna be
you
yeah you're a humble dude but you also
knew
you were gonna do this yeah yeah you're
yeah so you have the confidence it's
like
that you you know and you have to i'm
talking about there i'm talking about
you specifically
like i i'm wrong to say that you didn't
if you imagined this going
kind of like this yeah but i always said
i did
i wanted it but i never let my goal my
dreams or goals i never let them get too
far from where i was at at that time
so i never wanted anything too far i
never wanted to be like like i
right now i can tell you i want to be
able to sell out the madison square
gardens
i want to yeah but at that when i was
younger i never let myself
get too far because the farther your
dream was or goal was
the harder you're feeling it's too you
can't reach it i'm just i'm handing out
flyers
yeah so it's stupid to go one day i'm
going to be selling out the garden
well there do you know many steps there
is before you get to that yeah i'll
never
i'll never get there because it it it'll
get too daunting
but if i'm handing those fires out and i
go i don't want to have to stand on this
corner
well that's something i can get so then
once you get it
then you're you're you just keep doing
then you're like i don't want to
have to stand at the door i want to go
up i want to be able to go up whenever i
want to go up i want me to walk in you
know
the biggest thing especially for us new
york comics is hop in popping in
that like everybody always did that to
us and all you think is
and i remember like when comics would
get mad they're like why are they
popping you're like
how do you not just want to do that like
you're like yes
you're like yeah dude like i look at
when chapelle comes in you're like i
want to be chapelle
i want to be able to walk in and go the
reason there's three shows yeah because
they never know who the [ __ ] is going to
pop in
yeah it's not for us yeah i never have
resentment about people
that chappelle yeah as opposed to you i
never
i never understood but i hear what
you're saying though